bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag
c'est peu dire que l'économie et
l'emploi ont été durement impactée par
la crise sanitaire pour autant quantité
d'acteurs ont décidé de retrousser leurs
manches de s'adapter ou d'innover pour
relever le défi
à saint quentin en yvelines les grands
rendez-vous ont été impulsés en ligne
pour faciliter les contacts entre
recruteurs et candidats
nous verrons également en quels sont les
projets se dessinent pour aider les
jeunes des quartiers à créer leur propre
entreprise
nous sommes aussi allés à la rencontre
des acteurs de la formation en
alternance véritable tremplin vers
l'emploi l'emploi et la formation ou
fait tour ses vertus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce qu'on paie me parlez de votre
première expérience en garde d'enfants
pour la rentrée de septembre
cette entreprise spécialisée dans la
garde d'enfants à domicile recrute une
quarantaine d'alternants est tout autant
en cdi il ya un petit peu tous types de
profils nou sava à partir de 18 ans
évidemment jusqu'à des jeunes retraités
qui sont encore actifs et qu'ils veulent
qui veulent travailler
[Musique]
l'obligation pour nous si vous voulez
c'est d'avoir deux farces et qu'elle
nous est de minimum d'expérience dans la
garde d'enfant ou en collectivité ou au
domicile peu importe
mais en période de crise sanitaire pas
facile pour candidats et recruteurs de
se rencontrer pour les aider
l'agglomération a adapté ses grands
rendez vous de l'emploi serré le
giovannini s'est inscrit sur toutes les
plateformes disponibles
à commencer par ce qu'est emploi.fr et
ça fonctionne pas mal et pour
l'alternance et pour les emplois en cdi
classic l'agglomération de saint quentin
à mon sens est très active dans le monde
de l'emploi et je suis preneur très
dangereux comme il était autrefois
preneur du ski emploi en pis on était
présent avec un stand et ça fonctionnait
vraiment très très bien cette année le
ski emploi en piste s'est transformé en
hidjab dating le 25 mars dernier sans
plus et on arnaque ça une cvthèque comme
s'appellent une cvthèque donc on regarde
vraiment tous les cv et les personnes
qui cherchent dès sa petite enfance en
fonction de leur spécialité une première
rencontre virtuelle avant un entretien
dans les locaux de l'entreprise si
affinités cyril giovannini cherche à
professionnaliser le métier je fais
beaucoup de contrats pros et contrat
d'apprentissage pour avoir fait de
l'alternance moi même c'est une formule
je trouve idéal le matin elles sont en
cours dans les différents lycées et
l'après midi elles font de la garde
d'enfants à domicile pour l'alternance
est forcément mettre le pied gir 1 à
l'étrier donc en entreprise donc elles
ont réellement de l'expérience dès la
fin de leur diplôme elles ont déjà de
l'expérience ça c'est un vrai plus pour
les employeurs en tout cas comme bon
nombre d'entreprises kangourou kids
s'adapte à la situation
l'agglomération fait de même pour
soutenir les entreprises du territoire
et relancer l'emploi
les secteurs du tourisme l'événementiel
la restauration reste fortement impacté
d'autres recrutent et demeure en tension
la santé les services à la personne
le bâtiment où le numérique saint
quentin en yvelines les sur le front
[Musique]
pour essayer d'être un facilitateur et
de rapprocher au maximum l'offre et la
demande d'emploi
la plateforme ce qu'est emploi.fr
recompte 1200 offres d'emplois sur le
territoire
treize mille candidats y ont posté leur
cv les structures telles que la cité des
métiers ou encore les missions locales
restent plus que jamais à l'écouté du
public
l'agglomération elle signale
effectivement d'un beaucoup d'événements
qui était prévu en présentiel c'était le
fameux ski en piste pour l'emploi au
vélodrome national avec près de quatre
mille offres d'emploi qui
malheureusement a dû être décalée dans
le temps
c'est vrai qu'on est une terre
d'innovation avec les plus belles
entreprises du monde de thales à airbus
à atos en passant par renault on a aussi
un vivier d'entrepreneurs qui est
extrêmement dynamique que l'on a envie
de renforcer le rôle du ski cube
d'autres accusateurs une nouvelle action
avec les déterminer qui est une très
belle association qui a été créée
notamment par un monsieur moussa camara
entrepreneur lui même et donc toute
l'ambition
grâce à cette association avec lequel on
a signé un partenariat ça va être
d'identifier des ambassadeurs qui vont
aller dans ces quartiers pour identifier
les futurs créateurs d'entreprise et
permettre à certains d'entre eux une
quinzaine pour la première promotion
d'être boosté accompagner pour réaliser
leur projet entrepreneurial il
territoire furieux également l'emploi
des jeunes par le biais de l'alternance
c'est le cas du job dating il ya eu un
événement spécial jeunes première
édition et puis une deuxième édition le
25 mars dernier
spécial alternance
[Musique]
le gouvernement a mis en place de
nouvelles mesures d aides qui vont de
5000 à 8000 euros selon l'âge du jeune
pour faciliter favoriser au maximum
l'alternance et l'apprentissage
[Musique]
pour celles et ceux qui choisissent
cette voie de l'alternance
saint-quentin-en-yvelines concentre un
très grand nombre de grandes écoles de
tout secteur ainsi qu'une université
nous avons fait le tour de quelques unes
d'entre elles faites votre choix
[Musique]
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines membre à part
entière de l'université paris saclay
celle-ci rayonne à l'échelle
internationale pluridisciplinaire elle
compte 19 mentions de licence iv
l'essence double diplôme très aiguë et
27 licences professionnelles 47 mentions
de master chaque année dix neuf mille
étudiants viennent s'y former pour deux
mille d'entre eux en alternance depuis
mes deux ans de classe préparatoire
j'étais sûr de vouloir faire de
l'alternance
parce que pour moi c'est un tremplin qui
nous permet de nous expulser vers vers
le monde du travail
donc pour moi c'était primordial de
faire un master en alternance
ce qui est avant tout différent c'est
l'organisation en fait des cours et le
statut des étudiants
[Musique]
les étudiants une fois qu'ils sont en
alternance sont des salariés détachés à
l'université et donc ont une double vie
une vie de salariés dans leur
organisation
soit deux jours par semaine soit une
semaine sur trois soit une semaine sur
deux ça dépend aussi un du rythme
d'alternance
eh bien ils viennent à l'université le
reste du temps il travaille l'entreprise
avec des missions qui sont en lien avec
d'une part un besoin d'appui de
l'entreprise un encadrement avec un
tutrice ou un tuteur d'alternance est
donc maître d'apprentissage qui en cas
de la personne et qui est censé aussi
l'accompagner dans sa montée en
compétence l'alternance en apprentissage
ou contrat de professionnalisation est
composé de quatre acteurs l'étudiant
l'université le cfa partenaires
l'entreprise tous facilite la mise en
relation des uns et des autres certains
fous quatre voire cinq années d'études
en alternance une première expérience
professionnelle ou contestables quand
vous êtes en alternance effectivement
vous êtes immergés réellement comme les
autres salariés dans une équipe et vous
suivez tout au long de l'année
la vie un pour le meilleur et pour le
pire du service dans lequel vous êtes
et donc quand vous sortez diplômés
finalement au bout de 1 dans deux ans a
fortiori trois ans nous n'est plus tout
à fait junior et donc vous allez pouvoir
présenter une candidature avec peut-être
une posture un peu moins débutante que
quelqu'un qui aurait fait y compris des
stations il ya quelque chose sur
lesquels les entreprises tiennent aussi
beaucoup c'est la question de la
socialisation c'est à dire il ya
s'habituer à un certain rythme de
travail un certain degré d'autonomie à
des règles formelles ou informelles des
normes professionnelles
contrairement aux idées reçues
l'alternance reste une formation
d'excellence
c'est plutôt une autre façon d'aborder
notamment l'enseignement supérieur de
concrétiser le plus rapidement possible
ce qu'ils apprennent
ce fut le choix d' emilie étudiante à
l'école pigier performance dont tu es le
début de ses études supérieures
l'alternance j'ai commencé en bts parce
que c'était aussi pour avoir un revenu
mais vous aussi bon mélange et le thé le
côté théorique et le côté pratique
[Musique]
quand on est nouveau c'est un peu
compliqué au départ mais a pris en
généralement ils nous prennent sous leur
aile donc ça aide on apprend beaucoup et
au final on a l'impression de faire
totalement partie l'équipe intégralement
ça m'a permis d'être indépendante j'ai
mon appartement depuis que j'ai dix neuf
ans donc c'est pas donné à tout le monde
pour la rentrée prochaine il y a déjà
déposé son dossier de candidature pour
un master management et direction des
entreprises toujours en alternance pour
les jeunes tout d'abord ça leur permet
de suivre une formation tout en ayant
une expérience professionnelle
[Musique]
la formation n'est pas à la charge de
l'étudiant et il perçoit une
rémunération pour l'entreprise
ça lui permet d'avoir un jeune a recruté
peut-être plus tard de pouvoir le monter
en compétences tout au long de sa
formation
et malgré la crise l'alternance a été la
voix de tous les possibles en 2020 on
travaille principalement avec les
entreprises du directoire mais pas que
que ce soit des tpe des pme mais
également des multinationales on s'est
rendu compte quand même que les
entreprises ont vraiment joué le jeu
sont vraiment investis
dans la formation de leurs jeunes et
dans le recrutement des jeunes a déçu à
l'issue des fins des fins de formation
autre secteur celui du numérique en
tension en 2018 l'agglomération à
impulser son campus numérique au sein
desquels cet organisme de formation ont
été labellisés en octobre prochain une
école de cybersécurité rejoindra le
territoire pour répondre aux besoins des
entreprises
à saint quentin en yvelines je pense que
c'est le bastion de la cyber or ni de
france
jean
mais aussi la proximité du plateau de
paris saclay qui est très très fort en
termes d'éléments constitutifs de
recherche et développement dans le
secteur dans la présence aussi de grands
industriels donc et aéronautique ou
spécialisés dans la cyber l'école de
1600 a donc tout naturellement pris ses
quartiers sur le territoire celle-ci
recrute à partir de bac + 2 bac + 3 de
solides connaissances en programmation
ou en informatique sont exigées les
principaux métiers aujourd'hui sur les
métiers liés à la cyberdéfense
principalement mais qu'ils demanderont
de la part des candidats d'avoir des
compréhensions soit participer à table
au programme une partie technique pure
avec des experts r&d et du domaine cyber
des professionnels du secteur afin que
les étudiants soient en prise directe
avec la réalité professionnelle mais
aussi une partie expression écrite
langue anglaise droit cyber là encore en
alternance
le problème c'est le coût à une
formation d'ingénieur ou assimilés comme
tel est entre 6 à 9000 euros par an donc
ce qui est quand même à budget très
important pour pour des parents donc on
voulait finalement enlever ce premier
frein saint quentin en yvelines est
aussi une terre d'agriculture non loin
de port royal à magny les hameaux
bruneau et marc nous ouvre les portes de
la ferme école graines d'avenir
propriété du territoire saint quentinois
le projet de la ferme école graines
d'avenir est un projet qui associe agro
écologie et enseignement innovants son
objectif est de former des jeunes dès 15
ans au métier de maraîcher primeur
[Musique]
la spécificité des écoles de production
est le slogan des écoles de production
c'est le faire pour apprendre donc
l'enseignement est réalisé avec une
alternance hebdomadaire on a un unique
et même mieux de deux tiers de pratiques
et un tiers de théorie les élèves
réaliseront ici les commandes des
clients du territoire qui est aux
conditions du marché
l'idée est vraiment de créer un éco
système gagnant gagnant gagnant entre
les jeunes les territoires et les
entreprises et donc l'objectif ultime
est temps que les jeunes soient trouve
rapidement un emploi durable auprès des
professionnels qu'ils auront côtoyé
pendant leur formation
à l'issue de leur formation les jeunes
pourront postuler dans divers secteurs
exploitations agricoles magasins
d'alimentation jardinerie entreprises du
paysage collectivités territoriales ils
auront aussi la possibilité de
satisfaire à une demande aujourd'hui qui
est le suivi l'entretien et
l'aménagement des espaces comestibles
urbain à savoir potager verger ruche la
sélection des jeunes apprentis
s'effectuera en fonction de leur
motivation évalué lors de stages
découverte
[Musique]
d'autres filières d'excellence en
alternance sont également dispensés sur
l'agglomération saint-quentinoise pour
lycée d'hôtellerie et de tourisme à
l'estaca école d'ingénieur ou encore au
campus des services de l'automobile et
de la mobilité
[Musique]
vous savez tous désormais sur l'emploi
et d'alternance à saint quentin en
yvelines
à très bientôt ciao
[Musique]